[Musique]
6 heures du matin l'elysée reçoit sa
première visite 2 une des rares
personnes qui a accès à l'ensemble du
palais qu il est presque six heures et
demi peut pas l'être commence à se
réveiller doucement
personne n'accepte en fait ça qui fait
rêver c'est toujours l'interdît en fait
à toulon où c'est interdit
la zone la plus interdite du palais et
celle qui mène au coeur du pouvoir
le bureau du chef de l'état situé au
premier étage
le salon doré est un chef-d'oeuvre du
style napoléon iii
depuis le général de gaulle la plupart
des présidents en ont fait leur quartier
général
je suis leur lejard du palais je
m'occupe de toutes les éloges du pas été
lésés et j'ai surtout la chance de
pouvoir rentrer dans le bureau du
président la république on se dit que
peut-être que ces présidents il ya là ce
serait ce un petit peu qu'un sa main
chaque mardi dès l'aube
geoana remet les pendules à l'heure et
donne le tempo aux bananes les petites
mains du palais notre rôle aujourd'hui
c'est justement d'être complètement
invisible et que personne ne s'aperçoive
de tous ces métiers qui existent au
palais comme ioana ils sont environ 800
à travailler au sein de l'elysée
ce palais est le centre du pouvoir
politique depuis 1874 quand il devient
la résidence officielle des présidents
de la république
vous allez découvrir la première maison
de france comme vous ne l'avez jamais vu
pendant plusieurs mois
nous avons vécu avec ceux qui
travaillent au jour le jour au coeur du
pouvoir
merci beaucoup de ce procès comme le
garde du corps du chef de l'état qui
sert au palais depuis onze ans personne
ne doit ne serait ce que touche et le
président avaient toutes les sauces et
de ce côté-là au chaud le chef des
cuisines
la sommelière où le chef de la
logistique
on vérifie la totalité de tous les
objets toujours le prestige la france 16
hommes et ces femmes incarnent
l'excellence française
ils sont des rouages essentiels de la
machine élyséenne ne change pas avec le
président et son la présidence dans les
coulisses d'un palais réputé
impénétrable
nous avons filmé avec eux les fastes
d'un dîner d'état
l'arrivée du roi de l'arène où chaque
détail compte
je suis le président de la république
nous avons vécu de l'intérieur la
préparation du conseil des ministres
pour la première fois les forces
spéciales de la garde républicaine ont
été filmées au sein même des salons
d'apparat ou s'entraînant dans les
entrailles du palais aller
allez encore plongée inédite dans les
secrets de l'elysée
[Musique]
c'est un jour en apparence comme les
autres qui démarre au palais au premier
étage derrière ces hautes fenêtres
le président peaufine un discours rédigé
par un de ses proches conseillers à côté
du bureau de françois hollande
le salon vert ou le chef de l'état se
réunit chaque semaine avec ses
conseillers
de l'autre côté du premier étage les
appartements privés du président
au rez de chaussée se trouvent les seize
salons d'apparat de l'elysée les gardes
républicains et font leur ronde chaque
jour
certains locataires du palais ils y ont
laissé leur empreinte
comme claude pompidou en 1972 qui a
commandé ce fumoir au design futuriste à
l'architecte pierre paulin à l'autre
extrémité du palais l'immense salle des
fêtes
oui lustres somptueux embrase les
cérémonies officielles
juste à côté le salon murat où va se
tenir le conseil des ministres
[Musique]
l'équipe logistique et déjà l ouvrage
didier 56 ans est diplômé de la
prestigieuse école boulle en bascule il
est bronzier d'art tu ouvres je tiens tu
ouvres et chef de la logistique de
l'elysée voilà on bascule et ont leurs
entrées on le clip il a lui même dessiné
et créé cette table autour de laquelle
françois hollande et les ministres vont
s'installer dans moins d'une heure je
suis un problème didier a pensé à tout
les tréteaux sont spécialement conçus
pour ne pas gêner les jambes des membres
du gouvernement
ok parfait
nathalie on peut commencer à mettre le
droit s'il te plaît en guise de draps
une nappe en alcantara tu veux alain
comeau sa vallée qui pèse plus de 10 kg
cousu main aux dimensions démesurées
on est sur trois mètres cinquante de
large on doit faire à peu près une
douzaine de mètres de long
ça fait qu'on va faire quelques mètres
carrés il ya même des studios qui sont
beaucoup plus petits que ça même
il ya des studios qui sont beaucoup plus
de 6 à 42 mètres carrés de quoi
impressionner wilson il vient d'intégrer
l'équipe de didier c'est la première
fois qu'il prépare le conseil des
ministres donc pouvoir faire tout ça
dans le palais de l'elysée c'est
particulier c'est pas d'étape on trouve
tous les jours ils n'auront pas pouvoir
pas conforme aux quelque part oui
wilson tu peux me reprendre celle qui
est juste a pas le président tu peux me
l'avancé un tout petit peu voilà en fait
ça fait partie de l'âme de la présidence
de la république il faut impérativement
qu'on ait eu une à atteindre essayer
d'atteindre la perfection en permanence
qu'une fois la nappe installer les
garçons de vestibule entre en scène
ici la rigueur est quasi militaire eux
aussi ont l'obsession du détail
c'est au cordeau que sont alignées sous
main vers crayon feuille de papier
le début du conseil des ministres est
imminent la garde républicaine se met en
place
créée en 1848 par napoléon iii elle est
constituée uniquement de gendarmes en
grande tenue de service
coiffés de casques à plumes et rouge ce
sont eux qui encadre les événements
protocolaires comme les dîners d'état ou
le conseil des ministres mais les gars
de républicains se sont aussi une
brigade d'élite la garde présidentielle
plusieurs dizaines d'hommes et femmes
armés présents 24 heures sur 24 à
l'elysée certains en uniforme d'autres
en civil ils assurent la sécurité du
palais et celle du chef de l'état
mike est le garde du corps de françois
hollande les pôles du président dans le
jargon sécuritaire et c'est mike c'est
une arrivée des ministres de beauvau à
pied pour ce premier conseil de l'année
comme le veut le protocole c'est la
musique de l' orchestre de la garde
républicaine qui va accueillir le
gouvernement
aujourd'hui c'est tous ensemble et à
pied que manuel valls ses ministres et
secrétaires d'état franchissent le seuil
de l'elysée
[Musique]
mais les ministres rentre tout juste de
vacances
laurent fabius le ministre des affaires
étrangères ségolène royal ministre de
l'environnement christiane taubira la
garde des sceaux je suis enrhumé dans le
désert jean yves le drian
le ministre de la défense a lui passé le
nouvel an avec les militaires français
au tchad
bernard cazeneuve le ministre de
l'intérieur est resté place beauvau il
n'a pas pris de congé
le chef de l'état arrive quelques
instants plus tard mike son garde du
corps ne le quitte pas des yeux
monsieur le président de la république
bien que pour nice mesdames messieurs
lycée socata mais moi je vous adresse
et elle
le conseil des ministres est un des
seuls moments où mike n'est pas un
contact visuel avec françois hollande à
tous c'est un début de conseil des
ministres le président le gouvernement
les secrétaires généraux de l'elysée et
du gouvernement sont à l'intérieur à
huis clos pour la sécurité va en fait on
encadre le salon de toutes les issues
notre côté c'est exactement la même
chose j'ai des camarades qui sont aussi
en posture de sécurité et à la fin donc
eu du conseil des ministres je reprends
en compte physiquement le président pour
sa sécurité une protection qui ne
concerne pas que le président et les
membres du gouvernement à la sortie du
conseil des ministres dans l'ombre un
garde républicain safer sa mission
ramasser les documents et autres petits
papiers abandonné aucune de ces notes ne
doit filtrer hors de l'elysée
[Musique]
tout est détruit à l'abri des regards
il
dans le palais la confidentialité la
sécurité sont une obsession permanente
[Musique]
ce soir là dans le plus grand secret
tout le rez-de-chaussée de l'elysée est
soudainement plongées dans le noir
alerte aux contrats mais je répète
alertes ont confirmé un intrus se
seraient introduits dans l'enceinte du
palais la garde présidentielle doit
l'intercepter
ces gardes républicains sont entraînés
comme les forces spéciales à leur
disposition un arsenal militaire
réservée aux zones de guerre
[Musique]
le séducteur hôtel de bord à sion aux
siens va pas des hommes lourdement armés
qui déambulent dans les salons de
l'elysée
au milieu des meubles louis 15 et des
dorures la situation a de quoi
surprendre
c'est la première fois qu'une caméra est
autorisé à capter ces images en plus
d'être le garde du corps de françois
hollande
mike supervise les simulations d'attac
de la garde présidentielle
[Musique]
ici le victor hôtel nous sommes encore
par oscar cas là le but de cet exercice
ce qu'ils aient un savoir faire au
niveau d'attaqué d'intervention c'est à
dire ce qu'elle a fait ce qu'on va voir
la progression
il progresse de nuit afin de ne pas se
faire détecter sans bruit sans paroles
d'élus qui a aucune parole et en plus
voir sans être vu
voilà on doit être entraînée quasiment
365 jours par an à tout moment tout peut
arriver
donc on essaye de s'entraîner au mieux
au plus près de la réalité afin d'être
prêts à répondre à toute menace
[Musique]
ok pour l'élément victor hôtel fin
d'exercice
retour sur le vestibule dans le
déplacement ils sont encore un petit peu
bruyant puisque banda des frottements
on se cogne à des certaines parties du
mobilier nous ce qu'on veut en fait dans
vraiment c'est d'être quasiment
indécelable est indétectable
en tout cas dans le placement les
menaces des terroristes sont prises très
au sérieux
en plus de la garde présidentielle
l'ensemble du palais protégé 24 heures
sur 24 par des caméras et des détecteurs
de mouvements mais à l'elysée
la sécurité n'est pas le seul secteur
stratégique
[Musique]
la gastronomie est un des étendards de
l'excellence française est une arme
diplomatique pour la présidence
c'est souvent autour d'un bon repas que
se négocie d'importants contrats c'est
ce qu'on appelle la gastro diplomatie
du beau jeu
toutes les sauces et de ce côté-là au
chaud c'est guillaume gomez qui doit
faire briller la cuisine hexagonale lors
des dîners d'état le chef de l'elysée a
été le plus jeune meilleur ouvrier de
france ça faut y aller faut installer
installé là dedans pas il travaille au
palais depuis 18 ans françois hollande
elle son troisième président
ce ses ordres une brigade de 22
personnes qui cuisinent plus de 80 mille
repas chaque année tous sont des
cuisiniers d'expérience presque tous
à bien délicatement super
kylie ann lui à 15 ans en formation chez
les compagnons du devoir
il va passer trois ans à l'elysée pour
tenter d'obtenir son bac pro
arrivé il ya seulement trois semaines il
semble pourtant avoir vite trouvé sa
place pour les piques et tuent les pics
de physalies sort il n'hésite pas à
glisser des conseils à ses jeunes
collègues
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il ya deux chefs
mes yeux des autres stagiaires sava
killian aujourd'hui on reçoit pas mal de
stagiaires de troisième et donc qu'il
vienne qui a commencé lui maintenant
vient et quelques semaines c'est lui le
plus ancien des des jeunes c'est lui le
chef des jeunes nés au début de sa
carrière
pour l'instant il apprend le métier
après il va falloir qu'ils se
concentrent qu'ils apprennent à
travailler qu'ils acquièrent une
certaine rapidité une certaine dextérité
dans le travail mais à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui c'est parce qu'on lui
demande alors d'aujourd'hui ce qu'on lui
demande c'est d'être à l'heure d'être
attentif et des patrons repart à la
place de killian se mérite
il fait partie des trois seuls apprentis
sélectionnés par guillaume gomez chaque
année un rêve éveillé pour cet
adolescent amoureux de pâtisserie c'est
une passion depuis tout petit j'ai un
peu grâce à ma grand mère ces gâteaux à
me demander toujours participé donc à la
fin je me suis dit je vais faire
pâtissier pâtissier
vraiment je suis à l'elysée et les
compagnons du devoir
je ne sais pas je réalise totalement
killian doit faire ses preuves à chaque
service pour que l' aventure continue
dans moins d'une semaine
ce sera son baptême du feu dans les
coulisses d'une rencontre sommet aux
côtés de guillaume gomez
kylie ann va vivre son tout premier
dîner d'état comme le chef cuisinier du
palais et son équipe
tous les salariés de l'elysée sont triés
sur le volet
leur casier judiciaire doit être vierge
une enquête de police ou de gendarmerie
est réalisée pour chacun d'entre eux
aujourd'hui dans la salle des fêtes ils
sont réunis pour entendre les voeux de
françois hollande
le chef de l'état se prête volontiers au
jeu des selphy
[Musique]
ça va
du coup
les employés du palais sont pour la
plupart des fonctionnaires mis à
disposition par l'administration ou les
collectivités territoriales depuis 2007
le personnel de l'elysée a été réduit de
presque 20%
ils sont aujourd'hui un peu plus de 800
mesdames messieurs je voulais vous
exprimer ma gratitude et ma
reconnaissance pour ce que vous faites
ici dans ce palais de l'élysée servir à
l'elysée c'est servir la république et
la france meilleurs voeux
bonne année
[Applaudissements]
ici quand un chef d'état rentrer il sait
qu'il est dans une maison du pouvoir ce
qui se voit et ce qui ne se voit pas
vous voyez souvent les photos d'élise et
c'est avec les gendarmes les gardes
républicains
et puis à tous ceux qui se mettent de
côté qui ne sont pas à côté mais qui
sont dans la discrétion
c'est près de 1000 personnes qui donc
deux présidents au président font valoir
l'excellence de la france autre temps
fort des festivités de fin d'année
aujourd'hui plus de 500 enfants venant
de la france entière débarque à l'elysée
françois hollande fait son apparition au
milieu de la cohue
mike son garde du corps n'est jamais
loin
aujourd'hui est le seul jour de l'année
où le président prend un bain de foule à
l'intérieur même du palais
j'aime bien l'oeil pour regarder
l'ambiance est bon enfant
mais les dizaines de personnes qui
interpelle le chef d'état en permanence
sont un vrai casse tête pour le garde du
corps
mike étendue prête à intervenir au
moindre geste trop familier personne ne
doit toucher le président
[Musique]
attention aux mains que les gens se
bousculent pas le président
ne touche pas le président
on essaie de rassurer son intégrité
physique également on peut avoir une s
ne serait ce qu'une personne avec un
crayon
sans faire exprès va toucher le
président de laisser le président c'est
que nous sommes là tout à fait que je ne
suis pas celui qui a vu l'équipe entière
dédiée à sa sécurité au sein du pari
cette équipe
la garde présidentielle travail au coeur
du pouvoir
elle est en première ligne quand le
palais vite une situation de crise
[Musique]
mercredi 7 janvier 2015
la france est frappé par l'attentât le
plus meurtrier de ces cinquante
dernières années
douze morts au journal satirique charlie
hebdo
dans les minutes qui suivent l'elysée se
transforme en forteresse le quartier est
entièrement bouclé policiers en civil
réd service de protection des hautes
personnalités ou gardiens de la paix la
présence policière devant le palais est
renforcée
[Musique]
les terroristes peuvent frapper
n'importe où même au coeur de l'elysée
[Musique]
françois hollande convoque en urgence le
premier ministre le ministre de
l'intérieur le ministre de la défense et
le ministre des affaires étrangères
face à l'extrême gravité de la situation
dans son bureau le chef de l'état
multiplie les réunions
interministérielles à huit clos
françois hollande s'entretient avec les
présidents obama et poutine le président
et les ministres sont informés minute
par minute et suivre en parallèle les
chaînes d'information en continu
jusqu'au moment où le chef de l'état
décide de donner l'assaut contre les
terroristes
le pays est en deuil spontanément les
salariés de l'elysée se regroupent dans
la salle des fêtes du palais pour
observer une minute de silence du
secrétaire général au fleuriste est
femme de ménage en passant par le chef
cuisinier guillaume gomez tous les corps
de métiers sont représentés
quand vous l'histoire au quotidien au
palais de l'elysée on vit légalement les
moments difficiles et c'est vrai que
tout personnel ici tout le monde était
touché tout le monde était content
verser ce qui était en congé ce jour là
sont revenus sans même qu'on ait à les
appeler il ya les très bons côtés puis
aller il ya les drames et les mauvais
côtés comme celui ci mais non mais là
pour faire le travail est plus bas la
vie doit continuer de travailler s'ils
ont ce moment où l'on se pose pas la
question en fait un peu froid
[Musique]
on
pendant une semaine l'elysée est en état
de siège
[Musique]
comme souvent en cas de crise mike doha
l'elysée le garde du corps du président
n'a pas quitté le palais depuis
plusieurs jours
ça fait réfléchir dans son travail au
quotidien
on pense à des nouveaux modes d'action
ou à ce qui pourrait être fait pour
améliorer encore davantage la sécurité
même si la sécurité était à un niveau
extrêmement élevé ici au palais on
essaie sans cesse de s'améliorer dans ce
domaine la protection de l'enceinte
présidentielle est au coeur de la
sécurité nationale si une attaque
terroriste visait le palais c'est dans
les entrailles de l'elysée que mike
mettrait à l'abri
le chef de l'état
[Musique]
la france entière connaît la façade
imposante du 55 rue du faubourg
saint-honoré
mais il existe un monde parallèle cachée
sous le gravier de la cour d'honneur les
souterrains de l'elysée des centaines de
mètres de galeries qui parcourt
l'ensemble de la résidence
présidentielle un dédale qui n'a plus de
secret pour mike c'est un virage à
l'elysée tout sécuriser les soutiens aux
six ont sécurisé la zone la plus
sécurisée
l'endroit le plus impénétrable de la
république est le bunker présidentiel
le poste de commandement jupiter il n'a
été filmée qu'une seule fois dans les
années 70 sous la présidence de valéry
giscard d'estaing protéger des
bombardements
c'est ici que le président de la
république peut déclencher la foudre
nucléaires équipés aujourd'hui des
moyens de communication et de défense
les plus modernes
cet abri antiaérien de 250 m² n'occupe
qu'une petite partie des souterrains du
palais est en fait ici la particularité
du jeu réalisé c'est qu'on retrouve tous
les corps de métier dans les sociologies
à tous les ateliers les sous sols de
l'elysée certes également en garde
républicain pour se reposer entre deux
cérémonies
celle là aussi que se trouve l'atelier
des fleuristes du palais qui
confectionne de nouveaux bouquets tous
les matins plus loin les 500 m² des
cuisines plus de 200 repas ils sont
préparés chaque jour par guillaume gomez
et sa brigade
c'est qu'avec pascal sur les
saint-jacques n'oublie pas les le
plafond à bord le fleuron de la
gastronomie française
c'est sous terre que didier le chef de
la logistique cash lui quelques-uns de
ses trésors
en fait on va accéder dans le local des
restaurateurs technicien l'art du
mobilier national où là c'est un peu la
caverne d'ali baba
dans cet atelier il conserve jalousement
des pièces rares qui ferait pâlir
d'envié plus d'un antiquaire cette
pendule une valeur à mon avis à serez et
ses inestimables
oui non on est là sur vraiment de
l'objet d'art hors de prix nation
derrière une autre porte de ce sous sol
hors du commun se cache la prestigieuse
cave à vin de l'elysée il y à presque
deux ans plus de 1000 bouteilles ont été
vendues aux enchères pour un total de
718 1000 euros le but renouveler la cad
avec le produit de la vente en achetant
des vins plus modestes
allez on veut mettre ici
comme avec cette livraison d'un
viticulteur du val de loire
la caisse est facturé 50 3 euros à
virginie la sommelière du palais soit
moins de 9 euros la bouteille
si nous devons dire merci beaucoup
malgré cette nouvelle politique d'achat
parmi les onze mille bouteilles de la
cave du palais on trouve encore de
nombreux grands crus incroyable dans
cette cave la plus vieille bouteille
je vais vous montrer donc c'est un
sauternes sauternes dont clic ou revin
blanc ni pour eux de bordeaux un château
rieussec 1906 donc là là là l'étiquette
est en effet plus du tout présente c'est
vraiment avec déception qui ne serait
servi qu'à la demande du président la
république
cette jeune bordelaise a travaillé
plusieurs années dans un palace parisien
avant de devenir la première femme
sommelière de l'elysée elle a l'habitude
de choisir les 20 que vont déguster les
grands de ce monde mais pour la première
fois de sa carrière elle a bien du mal à
cerner les goûts du chef de l'état
président de la république pour tout ce
qu'il fait du vin me fait confiance je
n'arrive pas forcément vraiment savoir
si puisque bourgogne bordeaux ou vallée
du rhône parce que à chaque fois j'ai un
bon retour sur tout ce qui nous est
servi contrairement à françois hollande
d'autres présidents étaient beaucoup
plus clair quant à leur goût nous
n'avons pas que du vin dans la cave on
en a gardé quelques petites choses vous
avez une collection de sacs et qui date
de l'époque de monsieur chirac chirac
était quelqu'un de passionné par japon
donc sur une belle collection de sacs et
également à une centaine de mètres de la
cave au bout d'un couloir
mike a lui aussi son qg
le dojo du palais
allez encore
[Musique]
taiana garde tous les jours c'est ici
que le garde du corps du président
perfectionne ses hommes au combat
rapproché
[Musique]
allez encore aller
beaucoup d'engagement à l'entraînement
pour être performant le jour on aura
intervenir tout simplement entraînements
difficiles il est facile il s'entraîne
dur parce que chacun d'entre nous ici ça
me prêt à l'engagement ultime s'avéra
donner votre vie voilà tout à fait ça
[Musique]
l'espagnol d'astana théâtre ans order
aller tout de suite tout de suite aller
[Musique]
entraînements et les parties techniques
et des parties physiques voire des
parties de combats assez intenses
j'aurai toujours pareil au plus proche
de l'arrivée les gardes du corps qui
travaille aux côtés du président doivent
rester présentable alors pour éviter les
blessures au visage
le port du casque est obligatoire mais
chaque entraînement laisse des traces
le parlement a ses limites
un petit nouveau s'est sorti du à
l'entraînement la sas en bloquant des
coups des coups de bâton des couleurs de
d'armes factices en france un petit peu
le caractère savoir prendre des coups
c'est utile dans la vie on va pas
forcément toujours avoir le dessus
qu'est ce qui est sûr c'est que dans
toutes les situations que l'on peut être
confronté faut pour réussir le pendre de
suite y at il des blessés c'est bon
allez on s'étire bonne douche
aujourd'hui l'entraînement et est
particulièrement intense
mike et ses hommes doivent être prêts
dans quelques jours un dîner d'état sera
donné à l'elysée françois hollande
recevra le roi la reine de suède et plus
de 250 invités
la france veut réaffirmer le partenariat
entre les deux pays
avant la conférence internationale sur
le climat qui se tiendra à paris fin
[Musique]
pour certains les préparatifs débutent
bien avant le jour j
[Musique]
2h30 du matin la france dort encore même
pas guillaume gomez le chef de l'elysée
ça c'est ton côté invisible du gîte
d'étape c'est vrai que ça fait partie de
notre job
même si les gens ne savent pas même si
même notre président ne le sait pas
c'est des métiers on commence tôt fini
tard si le chef s'est levée très tôt
aujourd'hui c'est pour arriver parmi les
premiers clients du marché international
de rungis
[Musique]
le plus grand marché d'europe vit la
nuit
douze mille personnes et 230 hectares de
produits frais qui alimente tout
l'hexagone
[Musique]
donc ça c'est ce qu'il nous faudra monde
guillaume gomez commencent à tourner au
milieu des turbos un poisson raffinés ça
c'est magnifique quand même s'il allait
bien
et à bombay les ouïes bien rouge l'oeil
bien vif
tout ce petit les murs là dessus ça
c'est de première fraîcheur donc là bas
il nous en faudra
entreprendre pièce 30 pièces pour le
samedi matin quelques jours avant le
dîner d'état
le chef est venu en personne chez un de
ses fournisseurs pour sélectionner les
produits qu'ils cuisinera suivant à la
lettre les directives de françois
hollande
le président a choisi un menu tout
poisson avec de la langue bretonne en
entrée et poursuivre du turbo des côtes
bretonnes aussi
braisé au champagne rosé la cuisine à
l'elysée est une affaire d'état
guillaume gomez tient à mettre en valeur
toutes les richesses gastronomiques de
la france on va pas aller chercher des
poissons
d'ailleurs alors on a la plus belle
coupe du monde 1
c'est bien de mettre en avant et de
montrer qu'en france on a en effet des
beaux produits et et que le terroir
français c'est ça non mais quoi emploi
des kilos 100 c'est un petit
ouais ça c'est aux bottines en termes de
tranches sur le plat j'aurai besoin de
mort soit un petit peu plus conséquent
donc du coup c'est bien de venir se
rendre compte de ce qu'il ya après la
qualité je sais qu'elle est là je sais
que rapporte soucie pas de souci mais
possède langouste qui viendront aussi
décorer les tables d'invités prestigieux
le chef d'élise et ne tolérera aucune
imperfection
est ce que je veux pas su repousser des
années cdthed comme ça avec avec pat que
parce que sur mon plat je garde dans une
proportion et et là je suis au max ou
faites gaffe
bien sûr toutes les pâtes et que mon ami
mais possible parce que là on prendra
vraiment celle ci pour la présentation
si la qualité n'est pas la sueur sur
même de langoustes et basse et c'est de
la perte sèche et ça moi ça passera pas
l'exigence chorale chef de l'état envers
nous et envers tous les services
techniques c'est que ce soit parfait
donc si on part déjà avec de l'imparfait
pour faire du parfait c'est pas pratique
n'est pas magicien ou c'est non et que
des transformateurs
on prend quand mus par un kg 130 aussi
d'un kilo cinq et trente roses de 1 kg 2
pour les 250 invités guillaume gomez et
sa brigade vont cuisiner près de 100
langoustes et 30 turbo c'est une des
plus grosses commandes de l'année pour
le fournisseur alors le chef cuisinier
obtient des tarifs imbattables
au final il ne dépensera pas plus de 50
euros par convive en matières premières
aujourd'hui guillaume gomez n'est pas le
seul salarié de l'elysée à s'être levés
avant l'aube
[Musique]
dans une autre salle les grossistes en
fleurs
[Musique]
on y trouve plus de vingt mille variétés
de plantes
deux fois par semaine c'est ici que
marianne lâchait floris du palais vient
s'approvisionner
c'est vraiment mon petit royaume j'adore
j'adore être ici ça me permet d'avoir un
contact déjà aussi bien visuel qu'un
contact humain avec mes fournisseurs
lorsque vous voyez toutes ses couleurs
ça vous donne envie de créer ça vous
donne envie de travailler de faire des
belles choses
et pour trouver l'inspiration marianne
peut compter sur maxime dont la famille
dirige une des plus importantes sociétés
de fleurs à rungis
elle cherche les roses idéal pour créer
ces 90 centres de table dans la salle
des fêtes
et sinon il ya cinq ans mais en ce
moment qu'on vend bien à times square
celle ci attend ça et ça tu pourrais en
avoir à peu près entre 500 600 kg
ailleurs aucun problème aucun problème
moi la salle des fêtes
tout est rose très foncée voir rouge ça
c'est vraiment idéal quoi c'est vraiment
la couleur parfaite à moussafer
harmonieux coûterait très harmonieux la
fleuriste en chef de l'elysée va
commander plus de mille roses pour le
dîner d'état
elle doit surtout trouver les fleurs
pour le bouquet principal une
composition spectaculaire de plus de 1
mètre 80 chez un très gros bouquet à
faire mais vu défier peut-être l'intérêt
c'est que ils sont restés là c'est long
quand tu veux le voir oui voilà donc tu
peux travailler des grands bouquets
aventis a fait à peu près à mettre 20
l'idée globale c'est que lorsque les
invités arrivent à la première chose
qu'ils voient ce sont les tables c'est
donc les fleurs les assiettes les
narcisses et c'est tout un univers en
fin de compte et visuellement il faut
que tout soit parfait et surtout que
tout soit agréable à l'oeil
une harmonie des couleurs tout aussi
importante que la qualité des plats pour
le dîner que donnera françois hollande
en l'honneur du couple royal suédois
[Musique]
trois jours plus tard le jour se lève à
peine le chef de la logistique du palais
est déjà à pied d'oeuvre
le dîner d'état est un défi pour didier
son équipe
[Musique]
ils doivent entièrement transformé la
salle des fêtes avant l'arrivée du roi
et de la reine de suède dans moins de 30
heures
attention il faut remonter au plus vite
les 25 tables qui vont accueillir les
250 invités du président si didier prend
du retard
c'est toute la machine élyséenne qui
sera ralentie tapissière commence déjà
installé les molleton les lingères sont
déjà sur le pied de guerre pour
installer leur nappe
ce soir les quatre lingère de l'elysée
sont réquisitionnés aucun faux plis ne
sera tolérée le but du jeu c'est de
veiller à ce que je bloque pas les
autres corps de métier c'est un peu
serré la commune c'est à dire qu'on
aurait pu nous avoir un peu plus de
délai mais bon la vie de la présidence
fait que fait qu' on est soumis à
l'agenda et donc il faut qu'on il faut
qu'on travaille
- la ligne peu importe les conditions
peu importe les horaires je peux
difficilement dire à l'entourage du
président excusez moi j'ai pas le temps
de finir je ne vois pas bien faire ça à
quoi free donc obligatoirement on est
obligé de ba d'être au point et de finir
dans les temps malgré tout 148 didier ne
changerais de métier pour rien au monde
c'est une passion parce que en fait on
est dans un musée comme si on était au
musée du louvre donc où tout est enfermé
tout est protégé tout est cadenassé et
nous on travaille de danse pour didier
le temps presse il doit commencer le
montage de la table d'honneur a
maintenant à remonter un jeu suit l'avis
des autres le président de la république
deux têtes couronnées suédoise et leurs
invités
ça me semble bien effectivement ils
dîneront dans quelques heures
voilà je retire le sommier bougez pas je
rentre les deux pieds à l'intérieur
cette table est la pièce maîtresse dans
la mise en place de didier
ok c'est bon pour moi l'assemblage se
fait au millimètre près oui ça reste la
table ça reste la table du président et
de ses invités
alors au début effectivement ça peut
être impressionnant moi ça fait 27 ans
que je fais la présidence de la
république donc ça me passionne plus
beaucoup mais ça reste effectivement il
ya toujours d'aider des personnages qui
sont un petit peu plus emblématiques
la nuit est tombée sur le palais de
l'elysée dans la salle des fêtes
didier va découvrir que même après 27
ans de métier il n'est pas à l'abri
d'une mauvaise surprise
donc quoi [__] faut refaire la table
fait deux fois que j'allais déjà non ce
que je voudrais être sûr c'est que dans
5 minutes on ne dise pas qu'on l'armée
comme c'était quoi oui mais là pour les
pieds ça va pas les tirs et a raison le
conseiller image de françois hollande
est le responsable audiovisuel de
l'elysée ont un doute
de chaque côté
ils craignent que le président et les
invités d'honneur ne soit pas bien placé
pour la caméra officiel ça nous fait
perdre du temps automatiquement puisque
tout s'enchaîne et tout tout tout ce qui
est des petits détails comme ça vont
effectivement nous nous vraiment nous
met en retard
et puis surtout mettre les autres corps
de métier en retard et attend qu'on lui
fait qu'on avait le président faux
tourtereaux défaire ford est monté la
table on va voir on fait les tests et
pour faire les tests
didier va tout simplement endosser le
rôle du président et son équipe celui du
couple royal
c'est toi la reine la reine du ciseau à
les rênes du ciseau et de l'agrafeuse
m'écoute sur la tête
je ne mets pas les coudes sur la table
vas-y lève toi pour voir le roi le
président on se rassoit
non il y un peu plus loin
[Musique]
voilà c'est bon là à peu près c'est bon
elle est vendue
merci veut pas nous faire re démonter
une troisième fois la table pour moi le
chantier va s'arrêter pour aujourd'hui
en tout cas le gros oeuvre est fait on a
plus que des finitions
on est bien tout et tout est clean tout
est propre et on va reprendre gaiement
demain matin merci messieurs
bonne soirée fin de chantier et à demain
frais dispos le lendemain matin 6 heures
les services de sécurité sont déjà sur
le pied de guerre mike dirige
l'entraînement de la garde
présidentielle
avant le dîner d'état il emmène ses
troupes dans un lieu tenu secret en
banlieue parisienne
[Musique]
dans ce matin une séance de tir en
costume dans les conditions de travail
donc là ce que vous faites vous percevez
deux chargeurs de 10 et vous met au pas
de tir à 10 m le costume cravate c'est
la tenue de travail habituel de ces
gendarmes spécialement formés pour
protéger le chef de l'état armand
position de services 34 ans de moyenne
d'âge
ils sont tous passés par des groupes
d'intervention d'élite avant d'être
affecté à l'elysée
être au service du président est une
consécration
les gardes du corps de la présidence
s'entraînent chaque semaine aux tirs
c'est bien ok et olives
aujourd'hui toutes les balles ont fait
mouche on va être face à des adversaires
certainement entraîner voire très
entraînés on peut le voir actualité à
l'heure actuelle donc pas faire
n'importe quoi n'importe où surtout à
l'intérieur surtout quand il a pu de la
population vous avez vu que la salle des
fêtes ça peut monter à 700 800 personnes
donc il ya un moment donné et ce qu'on
utilisera son nom parce qu'on aura le on
pourra le faire on pourra pas le faire
boulot stressant tout le temps voilà un
exercice on fait l'évacuation avec un
vip dans les conditions normales de
travail c'est à dire que le président se
déplace dans la salle des fêtes et au
moment des clashs mentir et ben en fait
on fait une évacuation ans met en place
c'est parti la hantise de mike une
attaque directe un tir contre le chef de
l'état
c'est ce gendarme qui joue le rôle du
président de la république
à l'aide d'une sacoche dépliable en
kevlar deux gardes républicains forme
d'une bulle de protection autour du chef
de l'état les autres font feu sur les
agresseurs en désengager van gaal pour
couvrir l'évacuation du président hu à
l'abri peut-être qu'à un moment donné de
notre carrière où nos missions sera on
sera blessé ou un peut-être me
heureusement tués mais voilà dans
l'action en août façon on n'a pas le
temps de crise
dans quelques heures plus de 250
personnes feront leur entrée au palais
pour le dîner d'état
[Musique]
ce matin paris s'est habillé aux
couleurs de la suède
la capitale se pare de ses plus beaux
atours pour accueillir le couple royal
[Musique]
le dîner d'état ne commence qu'à 20
heures
mais dans la salle des fêtes c'est déjà
l'effervescence la machine élyséenne
tourne à plein régime dans le ventre du
palais les cuisines aussi sont en
ébullition points car on à dire
c'est celle d'un avocat me guillaume
gomez surveille particulièrement la
cuisson du plat principal les turbos
acheté à rungis agrémenté d'un
ingrédient que le commun des mortels
utilise rarement pour cuisiner on a
préparé un fumet de turbo tomate et au
champagne rosé et là on rajoute un petit
peu d'acidité on rajoute un petit peu de
champagne rosé et là ils vont les
enfourner pour briser le turbo jusqu'à
ce que ce soit bien cuit et obtenir une
légère croûte qui va venir
enfermé en fait tout le jus et tous les
sucs du turbo
faut laisser cuire ouais
ce n'est pas dans la cuisine principal
que se prépare l'entrée mais quelques
mètres plus loin dans une pièce à 6
degrés ce dîner d'état est un sommet de
gastro diplomatie la diplomatie par
l'assiette
alors pour guillaume gomez l'excellence
dans le choix des produits n'est pas
suffisante
je suis super pose un petit peu plus
haut soit tu les laisses on crée du lien
bien les appuyer voilà voilà on est en
train de monter donc les langoustes en
bellevue donc qui vont servir en un
temps de présentation en même temps les
gens bien sûr peuvent manger des mets
gaillon donc il faut bien tout regarder
en dessous là qui est pas de jour qui
passe tout ça parce que le client fin de
convives il va pas regarder le plat
comme comme on le voit nous lui va être
assis il va le voir comme ça le place
donc il faut qu'on se mette exactement
comme ça pour voir
donc voilà tout est important dans le
service à la française il ya une
présentation un décor je pense qu'il ya
plus beaucoup d'endroits où ils font des
choses comme ça donc ça doit être le
dernier endroit ce soit ici on voit ces
moelleux c'est encore juteux cuisson est
parfaite
exactement
à l'elysée guillaume gomez n'aura jamais
droit aux éloges d'un critique
gastronomique mais il sait que ce soir
il doit être à la hauteur de ses
illustres prédécesseurs
on représente l'excellence française
bien sûr qu'on y pense c'est sûr qu'on
pense ce que l'on voit la ja et à la
pression médiatique tout ça qui fait que
que bah c'est sûr faux pas qui est le
problème terre entière va être au
courant de ce qu'on a fait et va y avoir
va y avoir des photos de prise va les
voir tout ça donc on n'a pas le droit à
l'erreur nous ça peut pas s'arranger
avec on vous à fleurs pas où vous offre
une coupe de champagne
notre travail il peut pas se faire sans
pression de toute façon après 18 ans
passés à l'elysée
guillaume gomez sait comment diriger
rassurer ses troupes
mais pour certaines recrues il s'agit du
tout premier dîner d'état
kylie ann 15 ans est apprenti pâtissier
il est arrivé au palais il ya tout juste
quelques semaines
donc j'ai suivi la cuisson
[Musique]
parce que si ça qui trop vite
l'adolescent va passer trois ans en
formation à l'elysée pour tenter
d'obtenir son bac pro de pression pour
vous à 15 ans déjà travaillé sur un état
aussi important un petit peu changé la
donne et c'est aussi une fierté
car les mathis rider
et a bien dormi cette nuit le succès de
papier
dès 8 heures elle n'est pas je me suis
couché sur
pour pas être fatigué assure
sega nous alors alors d'abord de la
langouste et ensuite du turbo proposé
200 sera xavi
à l'autre bout des souterrains virginie
la sommelière doit choisir avec le chef
de l'intendance le vin que dégusteront
les invités du président ce soir
[Musique]
tendance voulait vraiment et sur quelque
chose qui soit un peu plus est
mais ce côté un peu tôt ce thème si vous
avez pu démarcher les folatières ça se
passe très bien également
hervé guaino était officier d'intendance
dans la marine avant d'entrer à l'elysée
je pense à partir là dessus a du bon
moment ensuite pour le turbo brisé qui
sera au champagne
soit je vous propose aller sur en
bourgogne si vous voulez un ver rouge
avec un peu plus de structures entre
mois ont fait sur un bordeaux mais un
bandeau avec un simple lot ou un pomerol
tu en as et bourgogne en entrée on va
faire bordeaux remplace donc moi je
serai plus sur un saint-émilion avec un
château cheval blanc
ah oui
à chaque dîner sont d'un tout à fait par
rapport aux mais par rapport aux
convives également salle est au goût de
chacun et également au niveau
protocolaire la surprend des dîners
d'état on va tout de suite aller sur des
grands vins de bonbonnes de bordeaux
parce qu'il faut quand même représenter
les vins français et la france est donc
allée des pins à ses prestigieux
ce soir il n'y aura que des grands crus
sur les tables dont ce château cheval
blanc à 250 euros la bouteille et on met
le vin blanc donc consomme 30 bouteilles
de vin blanc et 42 rouges vont être
servis aux 250 convives
par expérience
virginie c'est que les invités boivent
peu lors de ces rendez vous au sommet
pour éviter les mauvaises surprises
la sommelière et ses assistants se prête
à un exercice périlleux
[Musique]
goûtez les 70 bouteilles dans
l'aristocratie ces bâtiments si on veut
pouvoir faire un beau service de
llorente pression parce que voilà on n'a
pas forcément droit à l'erreur dans
césar de maisons et même sur des
bouteilles aussi côté un accident n'est
pas impossible qu'à d'eau salée
bouchonné journée on met de côté ces cas
ont fait une croix dessus pour éviter
les accidents
chaque bouteille défectueuse sera
remplacé par le viticulteur
on a eu deux bouteilles de bouchonner un
semblant sur le rouge
donc là on est quand même assez
satisfait dans l'ensemble le président
devra apprécier les vins moi je l'espère
en tout cas
l'invité également
ça y est ça démarre vous vous arrêtez en
bas des marches et puis je viens voir
pour le déroulé dans la cour d'honneur
du palais l'équipe de la logistique est
à pied d'oeuvre et les raids
il errait le caoutchouc didier s'occupe
d'un des incontournables du dîner d'état
a effectivement là on va commencer à
faire la mise du tapis rouge
selon là le niveau de prestation on met
différentes grandeurs au niveau du tapis
tout tout est conditionné par le
démarrage en fait si le démêlage on a
quelques millimètres de décalage
automatiquement quand on va arriver au
fond de la cour d'honneur on va se
retrouver avec un mètre cinquante
centimètres et à partir de là on n'ait
pas droit
[Musique]
ouais voilà tu étais bien là c'est bon
ça suffit
allez messieurs on peut commencer à
dérouler c'est là qu'on va déjà voir le
premier jet si on n'a pas de problème
d'alignement
c'est la première chose que l'on chefs
d'état un roi ou quelque invité qui
arrivent ici va voir donc c'est la
première impression qui compte cette
impression elle est primordiale et c'est
vrai quand vous avez quelques paraît que
vous avez un tapis qui part dans tous
les sens où on zigzague uke pas face à
la façade il ya rien de plus désastreux
non non il est bien chef de la
logistique
didier doit avoir l'oeil partout à
l'extérieur comme à l'intérieur du
palais du gros oeuvre jusque l
ajustement des salons d'apparat où se
réuniront françois hollande
le roi et la reine de suède donc là on
vérifie la totalité le moindre détail
une doublure de rideau qui n'est pas
mise correctement donc là on est en
train voilà on va renouer tourments
revérifier la totalité de tous les
objets
on a besoin que là aussi toujours le
prestige la france
le prestige et l'image de la france lors
d'un dîner d'état
ce ne sont pas uniquement les dorures et
les lambris de la république
il y a aussi des ingrédients plus
inattendus comme chaque matin philippe
35 ans ce réveil en musique pour
chauffer sa voix ce chanteur lyrique
répète ses gammes pendant une heure
[Musique]
c'est un peu problématique partager
voisin voir les gens sont levés en
général mais mais quand même ça peut ça
c'est un peu embêtant parce que vous
êtes là vous faites un bon poisson j'ai
pas eu de plainte
on va voir cela ne saute pas tout de
suite aux yeux
mais philippe est militaire il
appartient à la garde républicaine g20
commémoration sommets internationaux
le jeune homme est l'un des tout
meilleurs chanteurs des choeurs de
l'armée française
[Musique]
hélas une capture d'écran qui vaut son
pesant d'or on était juste à côté de
barack obama ça c'est la classe non ma
classe qui nous laisse l fillon n'a pas
besoin on voit tout le temps c'est un
collègue de bureau
c'est ça ce serait pas tellement dire
les goûts des présidents pour la musique
sarkozy je crois qu'il aime bien carla
bruni et je pas sur mes voisins l'homme
je sais pas qui va plus au cinéma
décontracté en apparence
aujourd'hui philippe est en fait un peu
tendu
ce soir c'est la première fois qu'un
chanteur va se produire à l'elysée lors
d'un dîner d'état avant l'arrivée du
chanteur dans la salle des fêtes
ce sont les argentiers qui entre en
scène ce corps de métier existe
uniquement à l'elysée ce sont eux qui
doivent dresser les 25 tables de la
réception
gantée de blanc pour ne pas marquer
l'argenterie dans le service à la
française fourchette écuyère son places
et pointent vers le bas
à l'origine les armoiries de la famille
qui donnait le dîner était gravée au dos
découvert et devait être bien en vue
pour les invités ce soir
chaque détail compte vers assiettes
couverts tous les objets ont une place
précise sur la table très précise même
après 17 ans à l'elysée
stéphane ne se laissent plus
impressionné par le faste du décor
je devrais avoir 34 entre chaque
assiette
on va vérifier 34 son obsession ce sont
les cm 34 34
et surprise ou alors si on est bon donc
la ias 38 donc et une erreur de 4 donc
on va rectifier oui c'est grave parce
qu'il doit y avoir le même écart entre
chaque assiette mais comme l'étape sont
pas tout à fait du même diamètre voilà
ça pose des soucis
les assiettes aussi sont pas tout à fait
du même diamètre pour nous c'est évolué
si tout à fait une faute si c'est pas
parfait il faut que ça se faut crier
l'excellence ce soir à la table du
président encore une fois qui est de
couverts au cannet 300 il faut que ce
soit parfait donc on va prendre un peu
plus large à prendre 35
pour être à la hauteur de l'événement
stéphane et les autres argentiers ont
sortis des réserves de l'elysée
quelques-unes des plus belles
réalisations de l'art de la table à la
française sur chaque nappe plus de 30000
euros en argenterie et en vaisselle
verres en cristal couverts en argent
massif ou en vermeil
même après 70 ans de service ils sont
encore comme neuf
[Musique]
chaque objet renferme une petite partie
de l'histoire de france et de sa mémoire
collective les pièces les plus anciennes
sont ces assiettes en porcelaine de
sèvres délicatement entreposés par piles
de quinze ou vingt pièces
voilà bah écoute et 1889 elle va servir
pour le dîner des tares du roi et de la
reine de suède
certaines étaient déjà utilisés par
l'empereur napoléon iii quand il
occupait le palais la vaisselle de
collection qui ancien qui a plus de plus
de 150 ans forcément il ya un prix très
important donc oui on travaille que du
matériel très cher une valeur
inestimable ici c'est le patrimoine de
la france n'est pas très loin des
français
c'est ce qu'on montre aux résidents
étrangers quand ils viennent ici l'art
de la table la française les entreprises
françaises le baccara la manufacture de
sèvres le christophe et ses stars à
l'autre bout de la salle des fêtes
lionel l'adjoint du chef guillaume gomez
profite d'une pause pour emmener les
plus jeunes des cuisines admirer le
spectacle avant le coup de feu
on
kylie ann n'en perd pas une miette
plus on se rapproche de la teneur que
les invités sont importants
[Musique]
moi je me dis que je suis un ado sur je
ne sais pas combien d'ados tir après
déjà deux déjà d'entrer dans le palais
mais encore de cuisine et après qu'ils
se placent a servi au président ainsi qu
aux invités de la suède et
[Musique]
c'est quelque chose qui
qui ne se reproduira pas enfin j'espère
que ça se reproduira mais qui est très
rare déjà à mon âge surtout ce soir
c'est par le jardin d'hiver que les
invités feront leur entrée
c'est là que marianne l'achète fleuriste
place son bouquet principale vers toi
gilles non là oui là et là au tenant au
dessus juste là rien derrière méfier là
c'est joli c'est un bouquet d'accueil
lorsque les invités vont arriver dans la
salle des fêtes
la première vue qu'ils ondes ça sera ce
bouquet le blanc refait sortir un petit
peu le rose les couleurs puisque en fin
de compte c'est quelque chose qui va
être vue de loin
donc il faut vraiment que ce soit du
visuel je pense que le bouquet va plaire
au président et à ses invités
visuellement quand il sera fini
vous allez voir ça sera superbe ça m'a
un peu plus grand un peu plus loin
puisque tu es là même mais plus longue
les autres sont petits
[Musique]
je pense que c'est bon allez bohain le
bouquet correspond à l'effet visuel
souhaité par marianne
mais qu'en pense le directeur de
l'intendance sont supérieurs mais bon
j'aime bien parce qu'en fait il ya le
rond et il ya des émeutiers le déficit
qui dépasse à 5 heures du dîner d'état
le palais se transforme en fourmilière
ces grand messes de la présidence n'ont
lieu que trois ou quatre fois par an
mais l'avis de l'elysée
ce sont aussi des événements moins
protocolaire dans le parc françois
hollande et le ministre de l'agriculture
ils ne sont pas en promenade
c'est la première fois qu'un président
de la république
plante un arbre dans le parc du palais
un geste qui d'ordinaire est plutôt
l'apanage des premiers ministres dans le
jardin de matignon mais la symbolique et
l'a même laissé à travers ce chêne qui
grandira à l'elysée pendant des
décennies l'empreinte d'un président ce
jeune chaîne rejoint les quelques 500
arbres arbustes les massifs du parc de
l'elysée ils sont tous choyé par yannick
le chef jardinier du palais depuis 24
ans il arpente chaque recoin de ce
jardin vous avez 150 mètres de long sur
100 m de large 1 ha 5 en plein paris
vous avez des grands arbres qui seront
plus que bicentenaire
c'est quand même un petit coin de
paradis au milieu de paris un petit coin
de paradis
mais étonnamment le jardin de l'elysée
n'est pas un jardin à la française
ce jardin à l'anglais date de d environ
2781 6790 là depuis cette époque là on a
toujours eu cette image de jardin avec
ses grands arbres qui forment un écrin
végétal qui enserre cette grande pelouse
incurvé qui paraît éternel un peu comme
une mère une mère de gazon qui vient
mourir au pied des arbres au pied des
massifs
ce jardin c'est un peu mon
bébé sur nos séjours se dire m'exprimer
ainsi un bébé qui demande beaucoup
d'attention
chaque année yannick et c'est six
jardiniers plantent plus de dix mille
fleurs autour du palais là vous avez une
terre argile eaux limoneuses c'est
vraiment l'idéal pour le rosier
aujourd'hui des rosiers sous les
fenêtres des appartements privés du
président depuis tout petit j'ai
toujours aimé avoir les mains dans la
terre
comme disait ma grand-mère le bon dieu
t'a fait des masses et pourtant servir
je peux pas expliquer c'est ma passion
je suis dette dans un peu comme obélix
est tombé dans une marmite de potion
magique moi je suis tombé dans le jardin
comme on dit le plaisir dans le travail
c'est un peu des fois ce qu'on me
reproche mais tu passes ton temps à
travailler sinon c'est un plaisir
bon je commençais à versailles
versailles c'était déjà quelque chose
mais à l'elysée
rendez vous compte enfin bon moi mon
niveau je pensais jamais être ici un
jour le parc de l'élysée est une part
importante de l'âme de la présidence
yannick et ses prédécesseurs lui ont
permis de traverser les époques sans se
faner le bâtiment aussi réclament des
soins quasi quotidiens
classé monument historique seule une
personne est habilité à superviser les
restaurations sur le palais même la plus
minime elle a tout les seuls 1 sophie
semble avalin est architecte en chef des
résidences présidentielles
aujourd'hui elle a fait le déplacement
pour une fuite d'eau qui pourrait
provoquer un désastre dans la pièce la
plus prestigieuse de l'elysée on est au
dessus de la salle des fêtes donc
inutile de vous dire que les cette salle
des fêtes d'ailleurs qui a été restauré
rien qu'à l'idée d'avoir une fuite d'eau
à l'intérieur c'est même pas
envisageable
c'était vraiment très préoccupant et là
avec ces réparations il n'y aura plus de
fuite d'eau après c'est l'objectif je
pense à la prochaine plus monstrueuse
cichy rappelé vraiment il ya un énorme
problème
[Rires]
mais même pour assurer son étanchéité
hors de question de défigurer un
monument historique maya une cheminée
qui n'avaient pas de chapeau et donc il
flottait à l'intérieur
le nouveau chapeau ne semble pas
vraiment convenir aux exigences de
l'architecte
ça me semble très masters non tu es
vachement important
et encore ça vous dérange c'est moche et
à l'elysée ça peut pas être moche c'est
un monument est un pack moche être une
seule façon d'en avoir le coeur net
ce poster sur le trottoir d'en face
comme n'importe quel touriste qui
viendraient admirer l'elysée il faudrait
que ça se fondent dans lignes de la
façade
s'il pouvait disparaître ce serait une
terne vous voyez il amène
et là c'est important
[Rires]
ça modifie complètement la libye m ça
fait un peu ch mini du père noël
déjà ces couvertures l'hiver ouais c'est
sympa mais pour l'instant on la pose de
sa règle le problème
et puis on va faire deux on va
certainement le modifier là c'est sûr
qu'on a un niveau d'exigence ou quand ça
nous plaît pas mais voilà on s'arrête
pas là il faut que ce soit parti dans la
salle des fêtes le compte à rebours a
commencé
dans moins d'une heure et demie le roi
et la reine de suède feront leur entrée
au palais il reste encore une dernière
mission pour didier le chef de la
logistique
[Musique]
juché sur une drôle de machine ils
arpentent chaque centimètre carré de la
moquette présidentielle
[Musique]
je suis en train de faire les dernières
finitions c'est-à-dire tout ce qui est
nettoyage avec mon petit aspirateur
voilà je m'amuse à salomé autour des
tables avec toute la vaisselle dressé il
faut éviter de se louper ça passe très
près effectivement on est au millimètre
sur certains endroits là si jamais je me
loupe et que j'accroche une table où une
nappe ou quoi que ce soit vous imaginez
il ya plusieurs dizaines de milliers
d'euros sur sur chacune des tables et
ça ferait un peu désordre je crois
[Rires]
[Musique]
à une heure du début de la cérémonie
dans la cour d'honneur
ce sont aussi les derniers préparatifs
[Musique]
la garde républicaine répète sa mise en
place dans chaque rangée les chefs ne
veulent voir qu'une seule tête le 2 tu
avances
petit petit petit petit petit petit
petit petit aller à lens avance avant 60
ans
quand le 4 août et la zone était bien
vous recul à 2 merci
à l'arrivée du couple royal des dizaines
de photographes et caméras venues du
monde entier immortaliseront sanitaire
ils sont la vitrine du dîner d'état
c'est magnifique philippe le chanteur
lyrique vient d'arriver
super avec mathieu membres de la garde
républicaine comme lui ils forment un
duo depuis six ans
on
l'elysée est pour eux une grande
première
[Musique]
oui c'est impressionnant
chic
c'est pas qu'on allait être si proche en
phase 1 les gens sont en avance devant
et ça s'est joué dans la pression non
j'essaye de paille plancher
[Musique]
sans le ballet qui se met en place
l'accord barre donc voilà on est dans
les derniers mais fier aussi fier de
chanter ici pour le président de tout
donner mathieu et philippe seront
accompagnés par l'orchestré de la garde
républicaine
[Applaudissements]
ce soir entre opéra et concerto ils ont
prévu une surprise dans l'honneur de la
reine un tube suédois revisité dancing
queen
[Musique]
c'est pas du tout fréquents non non non
nous sommes hors caisse de tradition
mais des fous fait quelques entorses à
la règle c'est à la demande de l'elysée
et de jouer de la musique spéciale du
pays et donc on a fait un clin d'oeil
sur la musique de bal ou pas célèbre
groupe des années 70 et donc on vient de
jouer dans le son crime
philippe lui chantera un extrait de
donges dans un opéra composé par mozart
mais les deux chanteurs compte bien
surprendre les invités lors du dîner
d'état
avec un morceau plutôt inattendu pour
une cérémonie solennelle
[Musique]
grand soleil
mexico mexique
[Musique]
dans moins de 45 minutes
la cérémonie officielle commence plus
question de se fatiguer la voie à
l'elysée pas de loges pour les chanteurs
alors c'est dans une pièce méconnue du
grand public que philippe et mathieu
vont se reposer
la salle de cinéma du palais une
quarantaine de personnes peuvent prendre
place dans les fauteuils of dessiné par
philippe starck créé dans les années 70
la pièce est resté dans son jus
une petite dizaine de fois par an le
président organise des projections de
films français en compagnie de l'équipe
du film
aujourd'hui la salle de projection est
le vestiaire de philippe et mathieu ça
nous arrive de nous changer dans des
lieux assez insolite
quand on n'a pas des vrais loches a peut
être dans des parfois c'est dehors
compte vraiment il ya rien mais celle là
a un petit côté un peu original quand
même faut reconnaître parce que c'est
apparemment c'est la salle de cinéma
donc de l'elysée donc du président
probablement ils s'installent là c'est
bien moi ça marche
moi j'ai pas trop de musique de boutons
c'est bon donc je suis prêt avant le
match donc j'ai gagné qu'est ce qu'on
ressent quand on endosse l'uniforme bain
d'abord une certaine fierté faut
reconnaître d'avoir un éléphant
particulier du choeur de l'armée
française n'y en a pas beaucoup parce
qu'elle n'a qu' on est que 40 à le
porter pour les militaires on représente
côté solennel de l'armée et en même
temps il ya le noeud papillon niamey
dorures c'est le gala c'est qu'on est là
pour divertir
voilà de la devise un peu de la garde
républicaine commémorer honoré et
divertir à 30 minutes de l'arrivée du
couple royal en cuisine
guillaume gomez met la dernière touche à
la préparation des turbos le plat
principal
on les arrose mien on rassemble dans des
plafonds mais qui sont pas trop pas trop
abîmer le nourrisson la rose bien ça te
fait briller sa mais une croûte en même
temps dessus puis c'est le
c'est le champagne réduit avec le fumet
turbo tomates et qui vient dessus ça
vient faire une jolie pellicule devant
nous la difficulté sur un service à la
française c'est qu'il va falloir que
tous les plats partent en même temps
donc là ce soir on va envoyer une
vingtaine de plats 24 plats il faudra
que les places soient dressés et partent
en même temps les récurrences allant
même temps on va pas faire table par
table pour un peu plus de 200 couverts
on dresse maintenant
et parmi tous les plats du dîner d'état
il y en a deux que le ch et prend soin
de dresser lui même sur les deux paires
père pour nous c'est les initiales c'est
président de la république c'est la
table du président du roi de l'arène
donc on apporte une attention
particulière parce que si on doit
vraiment finaliser deux plats à la
minute ce sera ces deux plats là on les
fait toujours en dernier pour soi le
plus chaud possible et là donc ils sont
en train de dresser bien ici pascal on
va dresser ici le père dans 20 minutes
le dîner d'état commencent guillaume
gomez à une deuxième urgence à gérer
[Musique]
san mames contre monsieur à
le traditionnel briefing des maîtres
d'hôtel
donc messieurs bonsoir donc ce soir pour
le roi la reine de suède langouste bros
ce soir ils sont 80 pour servir les 250
invités une dizaine sont salariés de
l'elysée n'hésitez pas alors dur de s'en
prendre turbo braisé au champagne rosé
donc le turbo les autres des extras
recruté pour la soirée mais qui ont été
soigneusement sélectionnés
je sais pas comment vous faites mais en
tout cas le turbo ne sera pas tranchée
tous sont passés par les meilleures
écoles de teulière en france ou en
suisse
on administre ce soir un ministre
français un ministre suédois qui ne
mangent pas de poissons et crustacés
messieurs bons services à tout à l'heure
la cérémonie débute dans quelques
minutes
[Musique]
au coeur du dispositif dans le vestibule
d'honneur mike le garde du corps de
françois hollande comme d'habitude je
suis les pôles du président et je veux
assurer sa sécurité donc on voit sur le
président tout en restant effacée
puisque il ya quand même un protocole à
respecter et à faire attention
pour le moment le président est encore
dans son bureau
les premiers invités arrivent au palais
le roi et la reine de suède seront les
derniers à faire leur apparition
sans soleil une fois n'est pas coutume
le dress code du dîner d'état fait
plutôt dans la simplicité
pas de robe de soirée ni de co2 pis une
seule recommandation porter une tenue
sombre
axel le maire secrétaire d'état au
numérique et nasser al khelaifi le
patron du psg ont respecté la consigne
la sécurité ça regardez les invités qui
arrive l'ensemble du dispositif
bon c'est pas le petit problème à droite
à gauche on a la preuve que tout se
passe bien
au mieux pour la sécurité du président
second billet renseignez vous également
bonne soirée on sait pas ce qui peut
arriver même
si c'est un homme quand même qui est
très sécurisé il ya un contrôle en amont
les gens sont connus les amis qui sont
connus le risque zéro n'existe pas donc
il faut faire attention à tout même dans
un moment où le prestige de la france
est représentée par
le dîner
offert par dessus le président il faut
faire attention quand même quoi qu'il
arrive
dans la salle des fêtes c'est la musique
d'abba qui accueille les convives grands
patrons et industriel suédois comme le
pdg d'ikea
[Musique]
et
quelques ministres et aussi des artistes
comme nicolas joly et tatiana de rosnay
romancière à succès dont les romans sont
traduits dans plus de 40 pays notamment
la suède
c'est formidable d'être accueilli à
l'elysée par rabat
c'est tendu
très joyeuse
dans la cour d'honneur fleur pellerin
ministre de la culture et de la
communication fait son entrée
accompagnée de son époux mais toujours
pas de couple royal
dix milles de retard les équipes de
guillaume gomez sont à l'arrêt pour la
première fois de la journée un petit peu
trop tard on a dix milles de retard sur
l'horaire pour l'instant sept minutes
exactement donc ça nous d'attendre
donc on attend attention ne s'assèche
pas dans les études faudrait pas que ça
s'éternise là c'est ça serait quand on
est dans la tente comme ça maintenant on
est pressé que ça parce que ça donne un
coup de mou dans le dans le service et
on aime bien rester dans le rythme
[Musique]
à
marco de mike est un renseignement sur
la position du cortège
mike leggo 55
[Musique]
oh
à tous et une essence de président
ce faisant
après un set
[Musique]
deux coups arrivé du roi de la reine à
l'ailé saint jacques au four garniture a
eu tout le monde à son poste qu'il y ait
eu prévient régis et cédric labat s'il
te plaît au chaud les gars j'étais moins
la coquille vide aussi là en bout mais
voilà on accélère un peu le rythme
d'entrée pas partie mais bon on va
falloir remettre un petit peu quand même
tout ça bien au chaud
abbas et la tension à ses services un
maintenant on attend on appris quand
même
une vingtaine de minutes de retard 2
ah les armes étaient bien au chaud et
augmenter les études là ça refroidit
vite
[Musique]
de la république
sa majesté le roi club 16 pouces table
de suède et sa majesté la reine
la sant et les parisiens après la
sérénade de philippe et mathieu françois
hollande entame le traditionnel discours
de bienvenue pour la reine et le roi de
suède en cuisine
les entrées sont fin prêtes son poulain
truc
guillaume gomez est informé en temps
réel de l'avancée de la cérémonie allez
mettez les plots sur un bureau show là
comment ça se fait que les uns jacquel
centrale
géraldine innu discours qui va nous
faire un coup quand le disco et terminer
comme ça le temps que le maître d'hôtel
man et sa table
allez les gars on voit les plafonds bar
à lait
c'est pas de la rigolade c'est
l'excellence a fait graver longtemps les
discours sont terminées le toast lance
officiellement le dîner d'état
[Musique]
on y va
allez pousser vous de la maîtres d'hôtel
vont passer la pousse toi plus moi plus
la laisser passer
allez mettez moi les plats au chômage
que là ils vont ouvrir la porte
[Musique]
allez
alex fait d'accélérer là j'ai un courant
d'air
ça fait un courant d'air dès qu'on ouvre
les portes d'un a refroidi tout et du
coup c'est pas bon donc il faut qu'ils
accélèrent un peu parce que
fallait aller plus vite asie ça nous
fait un courant d'air accélère un peu
flash est allé à l'italie c'est fini
avec ses 3 derniers là une allée des qui
nous unit à l'essai partie fermée tout
temps mais les ports augmenter un petit
peu les études mettez-vous à kotaku et
messieurs c'est bon aussi
c'est bon là
[Musique]
chaque maître d'hôtel doit se mettre à
une place bien précise
dans le service à la française toutes
les tables sont servis au même instant
[Musique]
l'entrée à peine terminée en coulisses
les argentiers reprennent du service
avec les ménagères ce sont eux qui vont
briquet chaque assiette échec couvert
maintenant tri l'argenterie d'un côté la
vaisselle deux sèvres de l'autre et on
va tout ranger ce soir l'argenterie et
la vaisselle des 250 couverts début du
dîner d'état
donc bienvenue dans la ruche
on appelle ça la ruche parce que voilà
ça bouge énormément sept jours sur sept
toujours à fond la vaisselle est arrivée
salle pour le couloir sylvain et felipe
des graisses toutes les assiettes
après on les passe dans la deuxième
pièce pour les laver l'argenterie
voiliers et dégraisser dans un bac l et
laver dans l'autre
11 les grands couteaux et les grands
couteaux l'écoutent la fois son ensemble
les fourchettes sont triés tous a essuyé
il ya plus d'eau tout va bien
la vaisselle passe ensuite dans la pièce
à côté
ici elle est lavée par deux plongeurs
essuyées par quatre skieuses et ranger
tout de suite on met des faits criant on
les range par piles de 10 de cases ou de
vin toutes les assiettes sont recompter
une à une il y en a plus de 7000 dans le
palais issu de la manufacture de sèvres
ce soir 18 personnes sont sur le pont
pour faire la plonge à la façon
élyséenne aucune machine seulement une
bonne dose d'huile de coude
4700 assiette à laver à la main
ça prend un peu de temps pour la toux à
la main que ce soit la vaisselle
l'argenterie ou la vérité et laver à la
main pour que notre patrimoine l'art de
la table dure le plus longtemps possible
il ya vraiment très peu de casse sont
nés sur 4 assiettes à l'année pour une
mauvaise année
dans le petit royaume des argentiers le
saint des saints est au fond de ce
couloir la salle des coffres où est
stocké tout l'argenterie du palais plus
de 8000 pièces en argent massif ou en
métal argenté
c'est le domaine réservé de patrick le
chef des argentiers il a commencé à
travailler à l'elysée sous les ordres du
président giscard d'estaing il y à 38
ans sa hantise qu'un couvert et disparus
pendant le dîner d'état
parce qu'on sait ce qu'est sorti
maintenant je compte 11 40
à partir de là qui manque une pièce ont
vite découvert et vous en reproduisant
les poubelles ça peut arriver si c'est
pas dans les poubelles c'est sous la
table c'est parce que la table après moi
je suis obligé de faire un rappelant
comme quoi il a manqué telle ou telle
caisse en cuisine c'est le second coup
de feu quasiment pas les 25 plats
doivent être servis chauds en même temps
à tous les invités
[Musique]
mettez-moi les saint-jacques à l'endroit
et à l'envers sur cela allez on y va
avec la traction
poussez vous poussez vous allez ici
allez on y va en demander plus
[Musique]
rien montreux
shaw a laissé refroidir chaud attention
derrière
allez on choisit accélère et sortez les
légumes sont les légumes suffit sur les
légumes les légumes
ce sont ce gâteau de pommes de terre aux
pleurotes d'île de france
[Musique]
attention c'est chaud
au chaud au cas où aller non le rythme
ici c'est pas à moi de donner moi je
suis en bas ici je donne vraiment comme
un jeu des jets un petit peu voilà à
sortir et puis à
schaffhouse toujours on a mais voilà
pour pas que ça refroidisse parce que
vous voyez là les plats qu'ils attendent
encore quand il faut que ça parte sans
légumes format chain voilà parce que les
places il est plat d'abord celui qui est
chargé de faire partir les plats le chef
d'orchestre c'est patrick core 2 3 vingt
ans de maison légumes
allez on verra après les végétariens les
machins ya trop de ya trop de détails
envoyez les plats envoyé le président
les autres après on verra
allez avec le sourire messieurs reste
plus que le dessert grâce à patrick la
chorégraphie des maîtres d'hôtel se
déroule sans accroc
pour le moment le dîner est une réussite
ces partis chaleur bien assaisonner puis
comme il faut le turbeauté pas trop cuit
on a toujours un petit peu peur quand
avec la tente que ça puisque c'est plus
sur cuir avant l'allergie parfait
donc là on voit que les gens se sont
bien servis il reste pas grand chose à
mon avis ils ont pris des belles
portions c'est bien on voit que la saint
jacques aux truffes
on s'est pas trompé tout le monde a pris
face à saint jacques aux truffes c'est
que les gens ont bien mangé
vous allez faire de tout ce qui rend à
bas alors nous aussi on doit être la
seule maison en fait il n'ya pas de
gâchis parce que l' avantage c'est que
personne ici ne choisissons nous à part
le président de la république
donc après du secrétaire général jusqu
aux agents tout le personnel de la
présence de rats public va pouvoir
profiter
on va faire la tournée du réfectoire
demain midi au personnel
c'est vrai que le personnel aime bien
les lendemains de dîners d'état parce
que il restera un petit peu de
langoustes un petit peu de turbo un
petit peu de potiron ça va
le dîner durera un peu plus d'une heure
en comptant les maîtres d'hôtel la
nourriture les vins la sécurité et tout
le personnel qui participent à
l'événement le coût d'un dîner d'état
est estimé à environ 3000 euros par
invité
pour tous les salariés de l'elysée la
fin du repas sont aussi l'heure du
verdict
leur travail at il été à la hauteur de
la soirée
sinon on a beaucoup apprécié merci
beaucoup monsieur le président à
transmettre aux équipes va tous dit que
c'était léger merci monsieur croisière
le vin était bien choisi si on se voit
large est équipé la con c'était parfait
donc toujours juste la musique ça fait
plaisir à nous autres
comme le veut la tradition lors de ces
réceptions
c'est par l'arrière du parc que le
couple royal suédois va quitter
l'enceinte présidentielle en passant
sous la célèbre grille du coq pour les
salariés du palais la soirée n'est pas
encore terminée 23h30 la fourmilière de
l'elysée se remette en route
tout le monde est sur le pont les fleurs
de marianne seront réutilisées dès le
lendemain pour faire de nouveaux
bouquets un quart d'heure la salle des
fêtes est rangée et nettoyée le soir
même dans quelques heures à peine les
équipes de l'elysée se remettront à l'
ouvrage pour préparer le prochain
conseil des ministres
[Musique]